we are starting with great news today
three Americans held by North Korea for
more than a year are back on US soil
this morning their names
Kim dong-chul Kim Hawk song and Tony Kim
received a hero's welcome overnight at
Joint Base Andrews outside Washington
President Trump the first lady and vice
president Mike Pence personally greeted
the men after their plane landed at the
base early this morning the president
hailed their return ahead of his
scheduled talks with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un Paula Reed is at
the White House with the significance of
the president release Paula good morning
good morning the release of these three
menacing is the most significant
accomplishment so far for the Trump
administration in its negotiations with
North Korea it's also seen as a sign
that the regime may be willing to move
past decades of discord with the US and
its allies ahead of a historic summit
flanked by the president and first lady
Tony Kim kim hak-sun and kim dong-chul
emerged from the plane as free men their
relief unmistakable after more than a
year in North Korean prisons this is a
special night for these three really
great people
president Trump called their return part
of his proudest achievement and he
thanked the leader of North Korea I
really think he wants to do something
and bringing a country into the real
world
Kim dong-chul arrested in October 2015
said it was like a dream and that they
are very very happy to be back home
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo helped
secure their release during a 90 minute
meeting this week with kim jeong-hoon
it was Pompeo second trip to north korea
to negotiate the details of president
Trump's upcoming summit my proudest
achievement will be this is a part of it
but will be when we
he nuclearized that entire peninsula
this is what people have been waiting
for for a long time first some this
morning's event was bittersweet I want
to pay my warmest respects to the
parents of otto warmbier the president
spoke of his call to the parents of otto
warmbier the student who is detained in
North Korea and returned last June with
severe brain damage he died six days
later his parents have filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against the North Korean
government yesterday they released a
statement saying we were happy for the
hostages and their families we miss Otto
despite years of bitter discord
president Trump struck a hopeful tone
for his historic meeting with Kim
jong-un we're starting off on a new
footing this is a wonderful thing that
you released the folks early and I
really think we have a very good chance
of doing something very meaningful the
three men are currently at Walter Reed
hospital for medical evaluation and
possible treatment as for that summit
sources tell CBS News it is planned to
be held in Singapore in the next few
weeks
John well thanks really great news